alors bien sûr l'été on pense avant tout
à la détente on peut aller se balader
aller en extérieur julien sauf que l'été
c'est aussi son lot d'inconvénients
égard un ennemi mois que j'identifie
pour l'été c'est le moustique il
bourdonne la nuit il est près de notre
oreille à la nuit nous empêche de dormir
le moustique c'est notre ennemi par
excellence justement avec vous on va
voir comment les éviter vous êtes un peu
notre sauveur dans cette émission doit
lire j'ai essayé de donner quelques
astuces alors non seulement dix
volontaires facile vous l'avez entendu
autour de la table petit tour de table
tu t'es fait piquer parce que ta leçon
sucre et à la pause sucrée ce que ces
leçons sucré on vous l'a dit tu viens de
manger du sucre ou autre chose comme ça
ben non ça c'est faux c'est une croyance
commune mais qui n'a aucun fondement
scientifique en fait les moustiques qui
n'ont pas la possibilité de détecter la
concentration de sucre dans le sang
alors moi je le vois quand je fais du
foot notamment je me fais un peu plus
piqué que les autres
les autres alors mais pas forcément de
répulsifs est ce qu'il ya une
explication du coup sûr pourquoi une
personne est plus sujette aux piqûres
que qu'une autre mais en fait
l'explication principale en fait c'est
l'odeur de la transpiration en fait les
moustiques ont la possibilité de
détecter grâce à un récepteur olfactif
c'est un radar à odeur en fait ils
peuvent détecter l'acide lactique qui
est contenu dans la sueur et vous savoir
que notre corps envoie dans l'ère des
centaines de molécules olfactives
et le moustique peut en détecter jusqu'à
150 sur le corps humain quand même donc
vous sentez bon pour les moustiques
justement il n'y a pas que les odeurs
corporelles un quartier qui attire les
moustiques in an il ya aussi le dioxyde
de carbone dans notre camp on expire en
fait valoir la bouche en fait les
moustiques peuvent détecter ses
émissions de gaz jusqu'à 10 mètres de
distance voire même au-delà et en fait
c'est il ya plusieurs facteurs qui
peuvent augmenter cette concentration de
gaz carbonique notamment le surpoids ou
encore la consommation d'alcool vous
faut arrêter d'espérer alors exactement
et encre sachez que la température
corporelle aussi une corde à une
température corporelle élevé à tirer
avantage des moustiques c'est aussi pour
ça que les sportifs et les femmes
enceintes bas sont davantage ciblés ça
c'est pour les causes de pourquoi on se
fait piquer par un moustique pour qu'on
attire les moustiques maintenant des
zones résidentielles quand même vos
conseils comment les éviter ils en
furent et bien tout d'abord vous le
savez sûrement mais il faut éviter les
sources d'eaux stagnantes parme sur le
balcon on a souvent des jardinières qui
reste rempli d'eau après une averse pour
leur dso aussi par ailleurs rempli d'eau
ça il faut éviter parce qu'en fait c'est
là dedans que les que les femelles vont
poule leurs oeufs à la surface de l'eau
ou simplement donc sextuplé
prolifération à côté des rivières
et s'explique voilà c'est la raison est
aussi voir si l'astuce d'appliquer des
lotions répulsive sur la peau ou sur les
vêtements en fait les achats les agents
actifs qui sont présents dans ces
produits bloque les récepteurs olfactifs
des moustiques et donc vous êtes plus
ciblés par contre attention aussi à
éviter pour les femmes dans certains
autres conseils il faut aussi
privilégier des vêtements clairs car les
moustiques sont davantage attirés par
les couleurs foncées ses couleurs
foncées et oui
en fait la chemise blanche ça passe mais
la veille
n'était pas sous les couleurs foncées
attire d'appât garde plus la chaleur et
vu que les moustiques sont attirés par
la chaleur il va d'abord ciblé c'est ça
et aussi bourru il faut aussi opter pour
des vêtements amples parce que des
moustiques peuvent vous piquez si la
tenue est trop près du corps
et l'utilisation d'un ventilateur aussi
conseiller vous pouvez peindre dans
votre chambre laisser un ventilateur à
faible vitesse du coup le moustique va
peut pas lutter contre les flux d'air
est en fait il va il va pas pouvoir vous
piquez donc ça c'est une astuce
intéressante et enfin dernière astuce
voilà la plus connue peut être les deux
mètres une moustiquaire sur sa fenêtre
pour éviter que les filles bien sûr des
intrus ne rentrent chez eux merci pour
tous ces bons conseils bravo parce que
c'est une première pour vous c'est que
c'était pas facile en avant que vous y
ajouter quelque chose donc dernier à
l'animation ouais vous sachez que ces
seules les femelles piquent en fait
pourquoi koala
moi j'ai entendu tout être une légende
urbaine en boîte ce soit le mal où la
femelle qui font le bruit pour en fait
divertir et en fait c'est l'autre qui
pique est ce que c'est je ne sais pas
mais
si rambarde c'est pas juste pour le
plaisir en tout cas qu'elle vous piquent
la femelle c'est parce qu'en fait vous
prévu une dose de sang pour loire les
deux tout simplement c'est se moquer